*Weird voice* Mark: Hello, everybody!
My name is Markplier, and I'm joined by Rosanna Pansino!
Rosanna: Hello!
Also known as Ro!
She does Nerdy Nummies!
Rosanna: NERDY NUMMIES!!!
If you're wondering why the hell I'm talking like this,
it's cusss it's squeezing my neck into my jaw! (That must hurt)
Ow! *both laugh*
Anyway, welcome to the Wet Head Challenge.
ULTIMATE EDITION!
By Ultimate Edition, it means that we're putting some *Deep voice* RISK INTO THIS.
Weee're gonna play a game a Rock, Paper,  Scissors.
Whoever wins, (let's say it's me), gets the right to put on this hat,
and wager a number, up- to- 7- cuz- wagering 8 would- be really stupid...
*MMMM*
Even the regulated spinner only suggests 2 at a time, but...
Who knows how many turns it's gonna take to make this
*LOUD CLICKING NOISES*
Hat of Death pour water.
Ro: Woo!
And we've replaced all the water with battery acid. (Oh god)
Ro: *gasp* MARK!
Mark: Uhh, as we were gonna do in the last-
Mark: Uhh, what?
Ro: We are playing to how many points?
Ro: That's all we need.
Mark: 12.
10.
Wuh... 15?
Somebackground guy: 15 i think-
Ro: We know the rules.
Mark: 13.
And a half.
I'll fudge the rules when I start losing, don't worry about it! *Laughing at the end*
Make sense? Good!
Ready?
Ro: Yeah.
Mark: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Awwww, shoot!
Mark: Yes! Okay!
So now we're off to a good start.
So I put on the little helmet here...
Ro: Uh huh...
And I strap it to my head, because safety is...
*Weird voice* First priority on this thing...
Ro: Strap it on tight!
Mark: I'm wagering... 3!
I'm going to pull three pins
It's freshly spun
I can't talk
Oh my god it hurts...
Ro: oh g-
Mark: One
Ro: Oh, Oh!
Mark: I'm okay (No your not)
Two
Ro: Oh oh ohoh oh
Ro: oh oh
Mark: I'm Okay
Ro: Ok, that's the recommended amount. The whole spinner only has one's and two's.
Mark: Three!
I'm okay! *Getting nervous*
I'm alright. There's a little water dripping but it's not the deluge that it was gonna be.
But is not the deluge that it was gonna be.
Three pooiints!
[Small clapping]
*Clapping and cheering*
[Sounds of applause fade in]
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Rock Paper, Scissors shoot!!
Mark: Yes! Oh-
Ro: [sigh]
*sigh*
Mark: I'm going for two
[Nervous laughter]
Roe: Here you go
Mark: I'm going for two
Roe: oh oh oh, oh Mark, oh Mark
[Steam noises]
*Mark screaming like a baby*
Ro: *Screaming*
Oh jeez
ah, my hair [laughter]
My precious hair
Ro: *Silly voice* Does that mean you don't get the points, or-?
Mark: Yeah i don't get the points...
I dont- iif you get water- you don't get the points.
Alright, we need a refill!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: [Gasp] Woop woop woop woop!
Okay...
[Several airhorn noises]
Ro: Okay.
Did it- wait, hang on, it's gotta be freshly spun.
[Loud clicking noises]
*Clicking Noises*
*Clicking Noises Continued*
Ro: Ooh...
Ro: Mark, will you wear my headband?
I- only if you want me to.
Ro: Oh, looking good.
Ro: Oh, lookin' good.
Thank you.
Ro: Mark, I can't even see out of this!
Ro: Mark, I can't even see out of this.
Mark: Too bad, you don't need to see, you only need to pull.
Ro: Oh, I gotta wager a number. Okay, let's go-
Ro: What did you pick the first time?
I picked three.
Ro: Three?
Yeah.
Ro: I'm gonna do... I gonna- no.
Ro: I'm gonna- I'm gonna
[Laugh]
*Mark Laughs*
Mark: No!
Ro: I'm gonna- I'm gonna do three.
Okay.
Ro: Yeah. No, you just pull out the pin?
You just pull out the pin, yeah.
(We believe in you Ro)
Ro: Oh, jeez
[Both laugh]
Ro: Technical difficulties, guys, we got this
[Off camera]: Here, hold the hat with one hand.
Ro: Okay.
Ro: [Whimper]
Ro: [Frightened noises]
[Laughing] Man, you've like switched between three different ones
Ro: [Laughs] Did I?
Yeah!
Ro: [Exhales]
I feel like one of those was the death.
Ro: One of them's the death?
Yeah, death.
Ro: Oh no, which one was it??
I don't know.
Ro: Uh oh, okay I'm feeling lucky. I feel like this is a good one.
Ro: Oh no! No no no!
Yeah! [Laughs]
Ro: [Laughing] No no no...
[Still laughing]
Ro: Mark I wasn't lucky...
Oh...
Ro: That was- that was not-
No, yeah.
Ro: [Determined breath]
Score is 3-0 still.
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x2)
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x3)
Ro: Rock, Paper-
Yes!
Ro: Oh, yeah...
Spin the Wheel of Death here
[Loud clicking noises]
Yeah that's enough.
Ro: That noise just sounds medieval, like, it's like a old, rickety like turning crank where you're like
Ro: stretching people out. [Unsettled noise]
Cool!
Ro: [Laughing] No!
[Muffled] Alright, I'mma going for three again.
Ro: Okay.
Ro: [Gasp] One.
Ro: [Larger gasp] Two...
[Gasp] I'm okay!
Ro: Wooooah!
[Laughing]
I did it.
Ro: I don't even know if I wanna win this Rock, Paper, Scissors.
Ro: [Decisively] But I do.
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Yes- Oh, wh- No [Laughing] This is not what I want!
Ro: Here, I'm taking this back.
Oh... But that was my lucky charm
Ro: Lucky headband, I need it back!
Ro: [Tiny gasp]
Ro: Aaaahhhh!
Aww come on, this is bullcrap!
Mark: Awww... Come on! This is bullcrap!
Ro: Awwwww...
Ro: Ooooh, Mark you were so close!
[Crying]
Ro: So close!
Okay, score's 6-0
Let's do this!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x2)
Ro: Yes!
Ok...
Ro: Alright!
You gotta- Wait!
Ro: Oh, oh!
Wooah, waa-ait
[Loud clicking noises]
Ro: Oh no!
Ok, that's enough.
Ro: I'm just gonna go for two this time.
No, go for three, go big!
What's the haaarm?
Ro: The last time we went for three, chaos.
You're down by six!
Ro: Oh, that's true.
Yeah...
Ro: Okay.
I just wanna cleansweep a thirteen and a half to 0
Ro: Wait a minute, Mark!
Ro: Are you tryina...
Ro: strategy me?
Yeah.
Ro: Okay, I'm going for two.
Aw..
Ro: First one.
Kay... [Laughs]
Ro: We're good, we're good, we're good!
Ro: One pin down,
Ro: second one to go.
Hokay!
Ro: Ooooh! Oh oh ooh!
You actually got some points, which is amazing.
Ro: Two points!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Dangit!
Yesh!
Ro: [Foiled noise]
I got it
Okay, I'm gonna go for two as well.
Ro: Okay.
What are the odds the pins right next to the ones you chose are gonna be bad?
[Shared, scared gasps]
Okay, alright
Okay, alright (x2)
Ro: You could have done three, maybe.
Ro: Oh, oh oh!
Yeah!!
Ro: I'm shocked.
I got eight!
Ro: Well how many do I have?
You have two [Laughs]
Ro: Two.
Ro: Okay. [Laughs]
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: [Whipers] Yes!
[Gasp of defeat]
Ro: Ok, I'm just gonna do one.
Oh, sure.
Ro: 'Cause this is a very dangerous hat right now
Uh huh
Ro: I-
Ro: Mark, this is a *dangerous* hat.
I'm aware.
Ro: Okay, which pin is gonna get me- I just want one.
Yeah.
Ro: Okay. I feel like this one's gonna be good, so I'm gonna go the opposite [Laughs]
Ro: [Face of shock]
[Laughing] Yeah!! Why do you look at me so creepy like that?
Ro: I'm shocked!
Oh, okay.
Ro: That's my shocked face, I'm shocked that that worked!
I just thought it was the battery acid just dissolving your skull
Ro: Does it looks really... really creepy? [Laughs]
So you have three points, congraatulations.
Ro: Thanks!
You're really climbing the leaderboard.
Ro: Yeah I am!
[Both] Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
[Both] Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x2)
[Both] Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x3)
Ro: [Victory noise]
Ugh...
Ro: Uh oh [Laughs]
Oh, oh good luck with that!
Ro: I'mma go- I'm gonna go with- I'm gonna g- I'm gonna go with this one.
Aww, come on!! That's not fair!
Ro: One more point, I got four points!
Ro: Yes! Yes! Yes!
You're just nickel-and-diming your way!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Oh, no!! [Laughing] No, no!
Yes, yes!! I lose! Yes!
Ro: Going for one :'^)
Mark: Just one, you don't want to try two?
I think two would be the strategy.
Ro: You're funny. You're real funny, Mark.
Mark: Alright.
Ro: You're a real funny guy.
Alright.
Ro: [Gasp of fear]
Ro: No, I- I heard something!
Ro: [Squeal]
Mark: Yay! [Laughing]
[Laughing] Yaaay!
Alright, it's 8-4
Ro: Mhmm.
I'm'na win this.
I'm'na win this. And we're going to fifteen.
Unless maybe it gets too close, and then we're gonna extend it.
So I win.
Ro: Oh, oh. Oh.
[Both] Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Yes!
Ro: [Breath of defeat]
Yes!!
Alright.
Alright. I'mma go- I'mma go for four.
Ro: Woah.
I'm gonna go for four.
[Loud clicking noises]
Two at once.
[Noises]
Ro: Two at once?
[Heavy breathing]
Okay.
We're fine.
Other two.
[Decisively] These two.
[Inhale]
yEAH!
[Laughing and crying]
I'm ok! I felt some water dripping and I was like
"Wait, nope"
Yeahh, I'm ok.
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Dangit.
I mean, well,
[Laughs]
Ro: Thanks, Mark.
You're welcome.
Ro: Thanks, Mark (x2)
I did it for you.
Ro: Ok, I'm gonna go for the one.
[Disappointed] Just one?
Ro: Uh, I really like the one.
Boring.
Ro: Yeah.
Ro: Boring (born) to be mild (wild).
Ro: Over here.
That's funny.
Ro: [Laughs]
Ro: You know what? I'm gonna go with the one right on the front.
Ok, yeah.
Ro: 'Cause it's like a unicorn.
Ro: and I love unicorns.
Uh huh
But if you pull its horn off, don't you kill it?
[Distress]
[Laughs]
Ro: [Laughs]
No, go for it! Go for it!
I wanna see if this analogy holds through!
Ro: Okay, we'll- We'll just test it out.
[Laughing] It's alive!
Ro: Lucky unicorn!
We didn't kill it!
Ro: I'll take that point.
Yay!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: [Breath of defeat]
Aahh...
Since I'm in the leeead, I'mma go for two
[Dissolves into laughter]
Ro: Two?!
Ro: Oh my gosh.
I'll go for two.
[Hissing intake of breath]
[Noise]
[Scream] YEAAAH
[Scream] YES!
Ro: No!
Yeah!!
Ro: Noo!
Ro: I don't want that hat. This is reverse!
[Laughing]
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, I don't want this one.
Ok.
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot...
Ro: No.
Yeah! [Laughs]
Ro: No. No.
Ro: No!
I had to think about that for a second
Ro: [Laughing] No!
[Laughing]
[Slow motion laugh]
Ro: Maybe it's broken, and it's not gonna-
Maybe we broke it. Yeah-
Ro: And no water is gonna come out.
Little did she know that it worked she was screwed anyway.
Ro: Nope. Nope, it works, it works!
[Laughing] It works perfectly!
Ro: It works, it works great.
[Laughing]
Ro: [Blowing water away from mouth]
[Laughing] Yaay!
Ro: 'Kay, so this is one more point and you win the game.
It's 14-5
How can I lose this?
Ro: It's not a close game, but I'm a good sport-
[Sigh]
Ro: Maybe I could have a comeback. M- Probably not.
Ready?
Ro: Probably not.
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: [Victory gasp]
Ro: Maybe a comeback.
Ro: Maaybe
[Laugh] I hope you get it on the f-
You didn't spin it!
You didn't spin it, you gotta spin it, you have to spin it,
Ro: Wait! I gotta spin it! Ok
at the beginning, you *have* to.
[Brief, loud clicking noises]
'Cause...
[Both laugh]
Ro: 'Kay, ready?
How many're you doing?
Ro: I'm doing a lot now.
Yeah?
Ro: Yeah.
How many is "a lot?"
Ro: Two.
That's not a lot!
Ro: Just kidding!
[Both laugh]
[Clap]
Ro: That was a joke.
Oooh one of-
Ro: I'm gonna do four!
Ooh one of-
[Suddenly serious] Okay.
Ro: Not gonna think about it. Just gonna- I'm just gonna
Ro: go, because when I speak, bad things happen.
Ro: So, just gonna think about happy thoughts
Oo
Ro: And puppies, and my little dog Cookie, and [deep breath]
Ro: She's so cute and I love her, and--
Ro: No, no no, nO, NOO
YEAAAH
Ro: Nooooo!
[Victory noises]
[Laughing]
Ro: Cookie, nooo!
[Laughing] Yeah!
Ro: Mommy loves you.
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x2)
Yes!
Ro: [Exhale] Dangit.
Yes! (x2)
I'll be a good sport.
Ro: Okay.
I'll pull four.
Maybe I should pull three.
Ro: Three's good.
Three? Three...
Three?
Ro: I mean that's a lot.
I think more than I need, right? Three's more than I need.
[Loud clicking noises]
Ro: Mark, three's a lot of pins.
Ro: Alright. It all comes down to this.
[Heavy breathing]
Ro: Three pins, Mark.  That's what you need.
Ro: Three pins, Mark. That's what you need.
One...
Ro: Oh!
[Scream] NOOOOO
Ro: Ooooh no, Mark!
NOOO!
Ro: Oh, no, Mark!
OH NOO!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot! (x2)
Ro: [Defeat exhale]
Yes!
Ro: Alright, Mark. You only need one to win!
[Loud clicking noises]
Ro: I feel like I should play a really epic song for you right now, but I don't have one.
[Nevertheless, queue dramatic music]
[It's so intense, I can't take it.]
[The world is on your shoulders, Mark.]
[Quick inhale]
[Scream] OH NO WHAT COME ON
Ro: Oh no Mark!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, Shoot!
[Sigh]
[Sigh (x2)
Ro: This is it, this is the comeback.
Ro: Molly, how many points do I have?
[Off camera] Five.
Ro: Five. Ok. All I need is ten.
[Laughs]
Ro: Alright.
Ro: I'mma go for three.
Ro: That's a good number.
Okay.
Ro: Un... (One in French)
Ro: Deux... (Two in French)
Ro: Trois (Three in French)
Ro: No...
Ro: No... (x2)
Ro: [Jazz hands]
Ro: Yes! Yes! Yes!
Yaaaay... [Slow clapping]
Ro: Shoot!
You just go paper first time, I'm- I'm learning now.
You go paper first every time.
Ro: You don't know my strategy.
That is- That is exactly what you do.
[Bling]
Ro: Um, I'mma go for one. It's go- It's gonna be this one.
This is BULLcrap
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, Shoot!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, Shoot! (x2)
Yes! Aw...
Ro: [Laughing]
[Laughing] What are the odds it's the same one?
[Mumbling] I'm believe in the unicorn
[Mumbling] I believe
[Scream] NO!
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE!
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE!
Ro: I'm still in it!
It can't happen this way!
Ro: 9-14
[Whispers] Okay.
Ro: It's 9-14, Mark. I'm catchin up
Okay.
Ro: I'mma comin! I'mma comin!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Ro: [Mischeivious giggle]
Ro: You were afraid I was gonna do paper so instead I do the rock. (?)
[Off camera laugh]
Ro: [Smug victory noises]
Ro: Three.
Okay.
[Awkward Silence]
Ro: One.
Ro: Two.
Ro: Three.
This is such crap.
This is crap.
Ro: I have twelve points now!
[Laughing] It's garbage!
Ro: [Laughing] I have twelve points now!
It's garbage!
Ro: Rock, Paper, Scissors, shoot!
Yes!
Ro: Oh, oh oh, dangit, I did the paper!
Ro: Oh no, no, no!
[Laughing] Yes!
Okay!
What are the odds?
--That it would be the front one?
It's impossible.
Ro: You only need one.
Ro: You got this, Mark
Ro: Pick a good one!
Yes!!
[Yelling] Yes!
Ro: It didn't!
Yes!!
Ro: [Clapping]
[Laughing] I win!!
Ro: Yay
Ye-e-e-es!
Ro: [Giggling]
I won.
I won!
I won it all! This was the- at stake,
Whoever won gets a diamond play button.
And I won! And I earned it, too!
'Cause I suffered. A lot.
At the cruel hands of fate.
So!
Thank you so much for joining us, thank you Ro for being here
That was quite a comeback! It was getting close.
Ro: Thank you!
I wonder if you'da gone for six to go for the win
if that would have been the better way to go about it, but
we'll never know.
And be sure to check out Ro's channel for another challenge that we did
that was very similar to this one.
The stakes were just as high, it was just as intense,
and, who knows who would win.
I don't know, because fate- is a cruel *bitch*
Thanks for-
Ro: That's her- that's her middle name.
[Stuttered sounds]
What is it- "Cruel-" Wait?
Ro: [Laughing] I don't know!
What is it?
Cruel B- Wait, what's her first name?
Ro: [Laughing]
But anyway, you guys figure that out for yourself. Thanks again, everybody so much for watching.
And as always, we'll see you...
in the next video.
Buh Bye!